[Musique]
Dieu que la vie est cruelle au musicien
des ruell son copain son compagnon c'est
l'accordéon qui sa qu'ilaide à vivre à
s'asseoir quand ils sen livre c'est toi
c'est moi non c'est
l'accordéon accordé accordé accordéon
l'omona l'accordé
l'accordéon ils sont comme cul et chemis
et quand on les verbalise il accompagne
au violon son acccordéon il passe une
nuit tranquille puis au matin il refile
un peu d'air dans les poumons de
l'accordéon accordé accordz accordz
l' l'accord et
l'accordéon quand parfois il lui
massacre ses petits boutons de nacre il
enfouche à son veston pour la corordon
lui empreinte ses bretelles pour
secourir la ficelle qui retient ses
pantalons en
accordéon accordz accordz
accordéon l'omonade d'accordé
l'accordéon mais un jour par laassitude
il laissera la solitude se pointer à
l'horizon de
l'accordéon il en tirera 50 centimes à
la brquante et on frera plus attention à
l'acordéon accordz accordz accordz
don
accordaccordéon accord accord
accordéon
l'ACC
[Musique]
l'accordéon